i think it was i think it was actually
troy that told me that he had to go
see a dentist mid
pandemic and the guy was like wearing a
hazmat suit
and but you know because the pandemic
but the funny thing was that he goes
he goes um honestly i don't think i'm
ever going back because at the end of
the day when i clean the the outside of
the the face shield i realize that was
all just unobstructedly coming at me
before like
what what the hell i i'm completely
reorganizing this profession and and uh
i i suppose it's in bad form for me to
tell a story on troy's behalf moments
before he has the opportunity to do so
but yes to hell with him this is a this
is a prompt this is this is we we
operate on a schedule here and if some
of us can't keep it then you know i
think it's okay if people don't want to
take the podcast seriously then that's
on them
i think i think yeah i think it's it's
perfectly we have this like uh jump and
jump out situation which is us
desperately clinging to keeping it
weekly as everybody gets busier and i
think we're doing okay we're doing okay
we are we are yeah go us also uh because
i started recording midway through the
plane conversation the context of that
is mike may have trains in his audio and
i'm pretty sure that i have a dishwasher
so it's just a really noisy episode and
also troy we think is going to join us
in about 20 minutes
i like the image of this
very fancy sort of
cigar smoking chamber library in the
background but just off camera the
dishwasher's directly dishwasher
like just the idea people have
dishwashers they just like they just
have a person who does the dishes rather
than yeah it is a yeah that's the job
description dishwasher yeah it's like
computers back in the day yeah yeah i
don't have a i always love humans
the job type that's didn't you see what
was that
hidden figures uh about the women at
nasa where their job like their their
job is they are a computer they com they
they make calculations for a living
computer is like an accountant we just
use it now to refer to the machine that
replaced all those jobs basically
what it makes sense
i know i thought that was i thought that
was one of those little
charming uh
charming bits of
you know i mean dishwasher's the same
right oh yeah what other jobs
are the products that replace the job is
now named after the job
hmm
there's got to be more
i'm trying to think of like because of
the
my head always goes blacksmith like is
always my first like what's an old job
blacksmith but there's no blacksmithing
machine
this one is a
this is not a perfect
it's not as good as computer but um
in the world of
like recording sessions especially
orchestral recording sessions
the people whose job is to
uh prepare the sheet music that goes on
the actual stand like of the violinist
or the cellist or whomever
not the one that's on the conductor's
podium but everybody else's
that job is called a copyist
um
for the reason being that in the old
days
uh the the the orchestrator would
prepare the conductor score and they
basically put it on a table and a group
of people would sit around it with
pen pencil and blank staff paper and and
literally really write it out all by
hand and that that was true by the way
through into the 90s like this is not
even that because notation software was
what it took to replace that there was
no typewriter-esque mechanical analog in
between like with word processing
because
people attempted there were there are
funny kind of
uh music notation typewriters that have
been attempted but it's just you can
hand write so fast and relatively
error-free
so the cool thing was there was this
period at the late 90s early 2000s
where the conductor scores were still
being prepared by hand but then the
copyists would basically
create the sheet music in the notation
so if you go and look like i was looking
at
um the john williams um
score to the movie ai
which is like 2001
and
yeah 2001 and the the conductor scores
are all handwritten but the sheet music
that the musicians are reading off is
all computer printouts wow so anyway
that job is called a copy of still to
this day even though
they're not really copying in any sense
of the word that it's just we just call
it that because of what it was back in
the day it's not quite as good as
computer but it's close computer is good
um related austin and i
saw each other this weekend i know it's
revelatory
i know i had a ad you could have invited
me guys you i would have jumped on the
plane
and then been turned away at the border
exactly but i would have tried yes sorry
that was very rude of us to not let you
try to come see john williams live in
concert 20
very good
yeah sunday night a religious experience
yeah i as soon as i bought tickets i
took the hollywood bowl as well it was
really cool i texted austin it was like
i just felt like you specifically should
know that i'm seeing john williams
tomorrow night and he was like me too
he's like what
so we met up it was wonderful it's very
surreal to
watch somebody who's had that much
influence on so many people in so many
different ways
perform that music like the godfather
was the piece that
got me the hardest i don't i don't clear
he did not that's all the hits i assume
you're getting every john williams mega
hit in that show right there's not
there's none of the new material it's
like it's hit after hit
it was
no it was um they did music from um
force awakens and it was funny because i
thought it was the the the solo song was
on the set list
is it called a setlist
yeah okay uh yeah the discography it was
it was uh what happens alana is the
copyist yes makes copies of all the
music
he was the one who conducted the
godfather though right he did uh
because there were two conductors i
think it was yeah david newman did the
first half of the show yeah last few
years
the only little sign john williams in a
few months turns 90. i know and the only
sign of his aging is that the last
i think four
or so of these hollywood bull shows
were he split the concert with um david
newman because he does three nights in a
row think about the fact that
a nearly 90 year old can sell
what is it 46 000 seats
um
and and and he's not a showman in any
way uh he's he's very polite and and and
professorial he actually was unusually
charming
okay he faked us out like four times
it's true he usually does i think he did
three he normally does two
they just won't let him leave
i was talking with our our little our
little group about you know when you
think about the number of things that he
could have done as an encore
like just the shopping list of viable
john williams hits like the his encores
were
were uh indiana jones the raiders march
and uh the imperial march from empire
strikes back and then ending with uh the
adventures from earth from e.t
and but to think like he could have done
jaws he could have done jurassic park he
could have he's not too dramatic
no no
i would want if i if i was dry i think
john should listen to me on this i think
well he
he also weirdly as a pilot
could answer the comments funny enough
there are a lot of studio musicians that
are well i don't know about a lot but
there's a there's a disproportionate for
that for for a demographic of people
that are all very specialized
professionals a disproportionate number
of them have pilots licenses
um which is one of those funny things
yeah right you can just kind of
i think it's mainly just yet
i just base it on harrison ford okay
he technically has a pilot's license
he doesn't want to be through something
can't be that hard to get
no it's because he's crashed like 40s
it's not just that it's not just that uh
he
he technically has one i remember a few
years ago there was like a hike there
was like a hiker in montana or something
totally gonna have to look at the story
to get the detail because
it's what's very blurry in my head but
there was like a hiker or somebody that
was injured and like a rescue flight had
to come get them
and harrison ford was piloting their
rescue thing just like unceremoniously
uh i i really hope i don't have the
details of the story action style
catchphrase rescues hiking i was in
if i was in the emergency situation i'd
want him to tell me that no no
they're all like please help me i'm
dying and he just goes i know
i'm on the whole
what would be the giveaway
if you didn't do that absolutely uh so i
have this
whoa whoa whoa sorry i'll still hide the
sound under a bushel
you just did a pretty good harrison ford
there austin give me back my family
without that's it we don't try anymore
get out of here
we can do it sorry okay forward star box
office blockbusters such as the star
wars series and indiana jones trilogy is
being credited with rescuing a hiker in
distress sarah george 20 and megan
freeman 22 were on a five-hour climb of
table mountain
they got dehydrated and was sick and
couldn't walk anymore so they called air
force one um
and
air force one that's what it says oh
sorry it says air force one star called
the wrong way around this is a foreign
um and so then han solo showed up in a
bell 407 helicopter
i hate the way this is written
oh my god i can hear that in your room
oh my god okay so but han solo didn't
need the millennium falcon yeah
the han solo didn't need the millennium
falcon for this mission he used his
slightly more modest bell 407 helicopter
and thankfully indy held onto his hat
when the weakened hiker had to barf you
can go [ __ ] yourself abc news okay it's
harrison ford use the word ford okay
you're supposed to the way you write
news is it's supposed to be as legible
as possible and you've made it all fancy
get out of here it's back to school
it's
the gloss is over it all the all the
emphasis on who he is in his resume it
kind of glosses over the fact that he
showed up in a helicopter rescue of this
person and they threw up in his
helicopter he did and it and and it's
it's sort of breezing past that like he
didn't mind no he had the best withering
look when that happened he just turned
around i was just like
and abc news didn't even report on how
he looked it says she vomited into the
cap of an emt worker well it was it his
helicopter or did he just happen to be i
don't know that it says he owned the
plane because they can't write
so
i'm very upset this news article is not
conveying the news to you
can i at least
so
it's
see here's what's okay it says idaho but
here's what's wrong with with everything
that's happening here
let me tell you about writing news
movie hero harrison ford got to play one
in real life last week
okay if i would have submitted that in
journalism school
they would have been like
what's the [ __ ] story harrison ford
got to play one in real life last week
being related to a movie tells us none
of the facts you're supposed to write
news like it's a triangle right where
like the most important information is
at the top and then if the editor needs
to for newspapers they can cut things at
the bottom to make it shorter and
shorter and shorter so every sentence
towards the bottom the whole story
should make sense without it this
doesn't make any sense
oh i'm very upset with you what's the
publication date on this let's see if we
can track down the author and give him
some year 2000
yeah let's uh
austin's jumping right like let's pile
up this guy no no no no not at all it's
like it's like we we have a journalism
school uh graduate who has some some
pointers for your next article and i'm
going to dox you politely
no it's it just says it's your beautiful
home
talks you it's very important to me
which we know has very clean dishes
exactly thanks to the dishwasher yeah so
it says it's idaho falls in idaho
from what year though like
okay yeah i was gonna say i have like
that i was in high school and i had this
memory that that was a high school era
memory for me
yeah it's pretty rad in any case oh it
was his own helicopter there you go e.t
online bizzali has reported it better
than abc news
well you know he crashed get one of his
planes into a golf course in venice
california once
oh i love it my gosh
um in any case
uh
yeah seeing john william i mean it was
lovely to see you austin in real life
you know that's a thing likewise
been since uh been since dice i think uh
last year pre-pandemic yeah good solid
years they're with you right
that was our that was our one moment of
play watch listen glory with the three
of us plus shoe
and uh
there's the i've been holding on to that
photo for a while that i intend to post
and be like play watch this and crew at
it again um but yep
yeah it was it was lovely to see you in
person and i'm sure we'll be able to
figure like people always ask if we do
panels at events mike is obviously the
more difficult
one there
personality
yeah no it's not it's not proximity it's
like you as a human
you sort of don't know if we want to
have this difficult difficulty hanging
with me i understand no it makes sense i
i you would you would never if i was
anyone else i'd [ __ ] hate me you uh
you never saw him at the ball before
right because this is like an annual
right tradition that's what i was gonna
get into no i've never i mean i've never
seen john williams perform before at all
he's performed the right word conduct
um at all and yeah he did come across as
very sweet
there was somebody who cheered at him
and he like turned around and did like a
sly little like oh
like that was the full kiana raves kind
of a little bit
it was it i genuinely i've i can't even
guess the number of times i've seen him
in concert and that was the only time
i've ever seen
that little because this it was like
clearly this young girl goes
and and the camera is pointed right at
him showing his face to the audience
that's 18 000 people and he just kind of
goes
gives us a little eyebrows and then
literally the entire audience just
exploded because they saw what happened
and then i think he realized oh they saw
that uh so then he kind of smiled and
did i was i was like man he he uh
he's not
he's usually so measured you know and
and uh but it's also his he comes from
an era where
you know
composers conductors that's supposed to
be a very dignified right profession
it's not um
it's not uh you know
like this leonard bernstein kind of
wild showmanship it's it's about
precision and it's about you know
um
making the music and kind of getting out
of the way of the orchestra he's got a
very restrained temperament yeah and um
for for
you know for all these people to just be
worshiping someone who's not nothing
about their personality is begging like
love me adore me it's just literally
it's one of the only times i can think
of where it's it's quite purely sort of
meritocratic it's like they just love
his work they love what he has
contributed to the world he himself you
don't have
any
yeah exactly you don't have like meme
quotes of him you know
that make the rounds like even you know
he he
he
and he's very well spoken and everything
but he just he's just like you know like
you saw a lot of he barely even spoke i
know almost nothing about his own music
you know he didn't in fact i was
laughing because the way he always
structures the show is he'll do
music from a random grab bag of his
stuff
um well sorry but the whole thing's
called maestro of the movies right and
so they do play stuff that he didn't
compose
how do they choose that stuff
uh just david newman probably make that
make the call he
he always would do that before and even
before he started splitting the show
with with uh
with david newman who is you know sort
of
you know got his own
uh plenty claim to fame including not
least of which is the uh
stepping into williams's shoes in a
manner of speaking in fashioning the
score
uh for the new spielberg west side story
uh film because there is no actual john
williams score in that film he's just
using the music from the show and making
a score
in the scenes that aren't the musical
numbers and david newman's uh
in charge of those arrangements but um
but no in the past williams would always
do the first half of the show may
feature a piece or two of his much like
this one like david newman conducted
something from harry potter for example
but the um but the idea was he would
usually focus on on some
theme to kind of tie together some of
the works like a few years ago
julie andrews came and emceed uh
on behalf of her ex uh her her her late
husband
um
uh blake edwards who was the director of
like the pink panther and uh breakfast
at tiffany's and whatnot and so john
williams uh did a
you know was conducting the music of
henry mancini for the films of of blake
edwards while julie andrews kind of
introduced each piece and they did like
they did um
yeah
the funny thing is they had such a big
missed opportunity because
you know the peter gunn theme uh was
like the detective show you know from
the 50s that that um
um
that henry manchester
everybody everybody knows the lick you
know it starts off with i know what the
audience wants
[Music]
you know that one it starts off guitar
then if you listen to the original it's
piano down low
and that's that's a young john williams
on the piano playing in the original
recording
and uh he was yeah he was the pianist
for henry mancini and you know this is
the piece that
detective classic tv theme and and it
was such a missed opportunity because
julie andrews just kind of says you know
and our our maestro over here also
played on the original and then i just
moved on i was like oh man why didn't
he should have played it was also like
john williams got something wrong like
he was like i think it was in this movie
where this happened and we were talking
about after the show how to him these
things that he worked on are just things
that he worked on he's like oh yeah
oh yeah i can i did that but to everyone
else in the room the 18 thousand people
at the hollywood bowl it's like
hugely impactful pop culture moments
that have shaped their lives and
inspired what they do you know and it's
so funny
like legend
is very surreal
the error that he made which is so
charming to me was that he said um he
couldn't remember which indiana jones
film the motorcycle chase with sean
connery in the sidecar wheels from he
goes i think it was from the second one
which is of course temple of doom and in
no way
that scene he's talking about and it's
funny because to me it was like
what because the third one is just it's
by far my favorite okay so i i'm sorry
to cut you off again
i just recently watched all three movies
i previously only seen the first one i
thought the third one there are only
three
yes oh come on well i have only seen the
three um i thought the third one was
fantastic but i had somehow picked up
along the way that people didn't like
the third one as much no it's the second
one that people are okay
i didn't like the second one that much
either okay one i'm i the second one is
yeah that that's the one that's just
a uh
tonally way different than the others uh
much darker whoa
there he is delson rowe
are we talking about the matrix
good guess
no we're talking about indiana jones
um
yes uh welcome troy troy has joined the
podcast austin and i saw john troy
entered the chat
he didn't
yeah
we could have we could have done a
three-quarters
uh play watch listen uh
photo you could have
but why it's true oh yeah it was let me
guess brutal was it colonel mustard in
the library with the wrench yes
correct did you right here look at him
i'm really sorry that's kind of what's
just in background i whenever i have to
present any kind of award or anything i
um use a fancy background and i've not
been called out on it yet sometimes
people think they're really calling you
out pierce [ __ ]
it's nowhere near as fancy as our red
carpets i know that was very good we did
earlier that wasn't mine that was good
truly a magical evening
all right what are your thoughts on the
matrix troy oh yeah why okay why don't
i'm just coming in hot with energy okay
let's do it
so this was recorded before the trailer
came out to be clear to the audience
did you see their little website gimmick
though
what do you mean how dare you sir i just
want to remind everybody that's watching
here in 1999 when this first thing
dropped
nobody knew what it was it was one of
the first
campaigns the entire marketing campaign
to be like we're gonna tell you as
little as possible about the movie
follow the white rabbit yeah right and
it became this trend that uh fight club
also followed that uh stanley kubrick's
last movie eyes wide shut followed we're
not gonna tell you anything about the
movie we're just gonna drop these
teasers
and
so much so that i went into the theater
i went i waited for that movie to come
out into what we call the dollar theater
which if you're familiar with that very
similar to the dollar store but in fact
it was one dollar to see a movie and it
was after the movies had done their
first run then it would go to the
secondary cinema house and you could see
it there for a dollar or if you wanted
to
wednesday's 50 cents all right so i
could go for like soda can cost
and then i'd get some hard candy
um from the general store
so i went in and i'll never forget this
it was the it was in the uh the big
theater to the left of four feet
theaters and this was like
it was the remedial
movie house it was not a good one
oh that's the whole thing those dollars
those dollar theaters had like the left
speaker is out the screen is
marginally larger than like a home
theater basically
there was there was the whole cinemark
was like the the brand of theaters that
were in texas in the dallas fort worth
metroplex at the time
and they had hollywood usa and that was
the big
megaplex and this was the
miniature version of that so you had the
same aesthetic you had the same vibe
just really really shrunken down and in
a shitty strip mall so i went in and i
watched this and i emerged two hours
later
looking at the world differently now
granted about the same time i think i
was no this probably would have been a
year before but i i was really reading i
was like reading dan brown and so i was
just looking at the world going with
super you know cynicism and going i
don't think any of this is real man
anyway
but the the cool thing is the website is
what first took me because it i remember
going to the website there was a couple
of things at the time that did this
um that it was this weird no one was
doing internet marketing and the matrix
was the first thing to do this and the
website that they had is what is well
what is the matrix.com
so today or or enter the aol keyword
what is the matrix remember that oh yeah
i just saw that keyword
i just saw that recently like someone
shared like an old trailer from around
that time wasn't for the matrix but it
was something of that
time period where the the billing block
at the end of the trailer would have a
big thing also here's the aol keyword
and i had this visceral moment of going
oh my god i completely forgot about that
whole thing before there were hashtags
there was aol keyword yeah so good
comparison i was like what is this thing
and i love that
here we are 20 years on and they still
haven't lost that edge
and there are different people have you
know done screenshots of everything
there are four stills that i could put
up that just from a cinematography
standpoint alone i'm like damn
it's just
beautiful what they did
um and the thing that i love about there
if you haven't gone to the website which
hopefully by the time this goes up you
have
um and you'll have seen the trailer when
this thing comes out but at this point
um i haven't seen the full trailer
because it's two days before it but
depending upon spoilers pause the video
if you've not been there yet because
you've ever been there moment
you have to walk outside does it ruin
anything for you okay where do i go
where do i go go to the website into the
matrix or what is the matrix.com uh what
is the matrix.com
and you will be presented with
a splash image of tooth the two options
the red pillow the blue pill show this
on the podcast great so if you choose
the red pill it will launch into a
teaser trailer if you choose the blue
pill
it will also launch into a teaser
trailer if you refresh the site every
time you choose it will show you a
different trailer
oh my god i didn't even know that i knew
so you are it makes an adjustment based
on what your
time is i know that the guests are
showing different trailers to different
people that's amazing it's over a
hundred different variations what
so this is some this is like the star
wars right this daddy daddy's about to
bring it home daddy about to bring it
home
you will very seldom hear me say daddy
about to bring it home i hope i never
hear you say that again let's bring it
home if we went the whole time
let's bring it home
um
you will very help them very seldom hear
me say i feel like the video game
industry needs to take a cue off of the
film industry but here's one thing that
i feel like
the video game industry on as a whole
still struggles to do which is we want
to go
wide appeal mass market we want to
hopefully be a system seller that gets
someone to go you know what i've been
holding off on spending 400 on a video
game console that's the game that's
going to make me do it
and people have hedged their bets on big
name actors or beautiful graphics or a
big ip or something else yes a lot of
you have a question
um
but i feel like
that's never really the thing it's like
the only time we ever see that happen is
with the switch or with the wii
where that's truly been a system seller
where someone goes i would be willing to
spend
x amount of money on that just because
of this one thing
so
the one thing that i feel like most
video game trailers do is that they
either the the dead island syndrome
where you completely misrepresent your
game in the interest of showing this
beautiful trailer that's not an
all-endemic of your
actual game
or you show something that really goes
niche and goes towards the people that
want and go okay that's exactly what
i've seen and
disenfranchised is their potential new
audience i feel like something even as
simple as this people who are gonna be
arms folded i'm not sure or i didn't
even see the matrix because there's 18
to 20 year olds
who weren't even alive when this thing
came out there's a whole generation of
people who have never seen the matrix
because we had this incredible time
where it was the matrix harry potter
lord of the rings and star wars all
coming out with a very short period of
time that's incredible it's like not the
zenith of cinema but pretty damn close
for nerd culture
so i think that looking at this as a
marketing component i would i would love
for the video game industry to go here's
how you can do smart marketing
that
reveals only what you choose to show it
but even in your marketing it's
gamifying that
um i'm really impressed i feel like i
had no idea the teasers were different
that's really cool i've seen like i know
the time thing but yeah you could like
you know in mailers which doesn't really
count as as marketing um i got one for
psychonauts 2 last week where you have
to wear
like they're basically like raz's
glasses
and then you have to like read a clue to
open something which like i i really
appreciate that kind of thing when they
do literally gamify it but you can't do
that for everyone and you know we have a
whole episode i was looking through the
old episodes about
trailers
but you know part of what makes video
game trailers so complicated
is uh the games generally aren't even
done by the time you show the trailer
right so you've got to put a bunch of
stuff that doesn't even necessarily
exist because maybe you hope it does but
maybe it can't into how many how many
games are the puddles and that takes
ages
gotta take them back out just to piss
the internet off gotta get rid of them
it's a whole thing or you do a lot sorry
austin i'm cutting you off i had a
comment though
uh i was just simply gonna say that i
think games have an especially difficult
task with regard to trailers when
communicating game mechanics
absent all the kind of tutorializing and
things that they do in the game but just
to get a sense of to the player what you
do obviously if it's a familiar genre if
it's a you know if it's if it's a first
person shooter or something like you
know players are kind of literate enough
in the the game designs but
you know if you're seeing a a less
conventional game like i don't even
remember
a trailer for
like gone home or something where you
know
i i i i think i purely got that on word
of mouth because because
i don't even know how you could do a
trailer that actually captures
what that game felt like to play
especially in a way it would have been
it would have been a boring trailer so i
wander around the house yeah
yeah but there's training
trailer or the the dead island where
it's very deceptive in the interest of
not being boring right
um i remember mercenaries two
had a trailer just like that where it
had this really great song that they
wrote for the trailer
um and they also can't be one right or
was that army of two no it was very yeah
it was very fun and it was kind of like
it was like comedy hip-hop in a way and
it was all the textures were these it
was like dollar signs was the kind of
texture over everything
uh sorry darler bills not just the sign
but like the full bill kind of was like
what their car looked like and what they
looked like and hanging off of
helicopters and they were thinking i
want to play that game right uh and and
the actual game was basically you know
that's the challenge of like
like i i literally just had to do it
while we were on the podcast is publish
a instagram sponsored video where i'm
playing oculus against a green screen
and it's
so hard to make vr look interesting
without just making it look like either
any other video game or making you look
like a dork yeah but there's two layers
of vr right it's it's been the one thing
that i feel like we
kind of
it was a spiritual successor in some
sense like you play a game
uh like i expect you to die or um
even just like the the standard stock
disc that came with the psvr the funnest
thing to do
would be to get grandma or someone who
had never done vr before
to do the shark experience and watch
them flip the [ __ ] out in your living
room like that is so much fun so to me
there's two layers of vr
um
i i hold true to
to vr i think that it is it will find
its place i think it's growing but it is
a huge leap we're still trying to get
people to pick up a controller
much less put on
gear and have a designated space
and and then
just the sheer amount of time that you
can be in there it's just super hard to
dev for vr there's a whole new way it's
also just hard to push past what you're
describing it's where
vr's you know done the
apocryphal tale of the train pulling
into the station and freaking everyone
out so i just hit my mic um we need to
convince people actually like watching
the movie on it like and that's the
that's the interesting thing like doing
a vr game now um we just we just put one
out called locksmith and making a
trailer for that was absolutely a
nightmare because yeah as alliances how
do you convey what's different about
that to be our the other thing that is
tough for a developer as well is vr is
an incredibly like efficiency based kind
of game development you have to make
everything run at such a high frame rate
that the graphics are very dependent on
that so if you take like footage from a
vr game and show it like 4k on a big
screen
it doesn't look as good as you'd expect
from like a modern video game on the on
yeah when i've recorded it it looks
terrible but when you're in there yeah
it's a real concept challenge and i use
vr almost every single day like do you
yes so like i just i just said i just
published while we were on this my
manager was like you need to publish
this oculus thing so i just published
that on every platform while we were on
this but if for me that was like getting
a sponsor of a thing that i always talk
about and always use so i use oculus
quest 2. are you in vr right now can you
do we forgot to be alright do you feel
like if you just reached out you could
like
exactly three no i i love it mostly
still for fitness games but yeah i have
my quest right there and i have my quest
dev kit up there they're very quest
two's lovely yeah i absolutely love it
but i've been playing uh keep talking
and nobody explodes with my mom remotely
so one of us will sit because i bought
her an oculus quest 2 for mother's day
again massive oculus quest 2 fan uh i
bought her one for mother's day so one
of us will sit in the headset and the
other one will have the print out so
it's like you can play a game like that
like it's a party game and you're in the
room with one another and we're still
working that sense of presence don't you
totally you find that like i i i
whenever i've played vr multiplayer with
someone like you genuinely you just if
you know someone's body language and
like how it feels to sit in a room with
them yeah you can just pick up on that
and it feels like you're in it it's
amazing we played a co-op and like you
can look at each other and wave and
stuff like while you're playing if it's
a friend or someone or a family member
or someone you know like
it's eerie in the sense that you just
all these body language cues that you
think just tracking ahead wouldn't give
you that but like they're an errand
it feels yeah but how do you market that
exactly like a trailer's not going to
give that concept but like
you know if you're if you're far away
from family or friends or a loved one
it's wonderful
and again such a great way to work out
that's i i really really like it um
related to that surely there's a matrix
vr game
i had a friend i don't think i think
one's been made because it predates like
the last time anyone was trying to
market a matrix movie was bro
it is
it's so good it is such a great matrix
was a really cool idea such a great idea
and that's the that's the one where
people are like why can't and and they
wachowski's shot
um
it's like 45 minutes 45 minutes it's not
like well this is the stuff we're gonna
throw away anyway it's like no no we're
shooting this specifically for the game
and can you imagine those actors at that
time like kyoto reeves looks like he's
down for anything and that's a whole
other conversation we get into i think
that guy's work ethic is incredible and
he talk about someone who has redeemed
himself because he went from bill and
ted's two almost getting fired on set
because he was showing up [ __ ] up and
unprepared
and
really turning it around to where he is
first in last out look at all and i
think it was really the matrix that kind
of turned him around
famous for it that's the crazy thing
like everyone in hollywood seems to have
a story about like keanu reeves being
a joy to work with yeah
and also just a good human outside of
work you always hear stories of
yeah you know
ah the philanthropic work and all that
kind of thing stephen colbert asks him
and he goes
what do you think happens after we die
and i was like you know great setup
question and he just kind of thinks for
a second he goes i am certain that those
who love us
um will miss us and i was like [ __ ] you
what a great ass
dodging for sure but what a great answer
he's a warrior poet yeah
but that that game still holds up and
it's it's it's one of the beautiful
things that i've i've wanted to see
somebody do i've played through it
recently too
um where you the the what's happening in
the cinematic presentation of that is
being supported and crossing over with
what's happening in the internet so hard
to do though it's so yeah just the
logistics of that is so challenging most
of the time it's because it happens you
need the wachowskis to make that happen
for well i think you also need the
vision because most people are thinking
it was like we're going to do a little
movie tie-in support and we're going to
give you a version of the script that
because you need two years to work on
this or maybe even longer to work on
this i've been on that project yeah
right for sure and we're not sure we
know these tentpole things and you had a
beauty of being able to use existing
cast a lot of i've i've stubbed in for a
lot of the people that were you know we
can't get obviously ian mcshane and john
wick was fantastic thank you
his troy baker though
terrible no actually i actually thought
i was like you know i think i don't need
to be me anymore i don't think it works
oh so good i missed him by five minutes
one time um that's my closest em
exchange story it's probably best
because i would have embarrassed myself
it would have been bad
um
but that's that's where i feel like most
people who try to do a
video game
movie
[ __ ] it up is because they they either
are playing
too
too far outside
and there everyone's keeping secrets
or
they are working up an old version of
the script and no one bothered to update
them or
um
no one just really had the foresight to
be able to go why don't we integrate
this into it and we just specifically
shoot our movie in such a way that says
this will be supported we will
fig feature and figure this out in this
version of this i think it that's the
verticality of the ip that's what
everyone's chasing now i'm very
interested
it's so much like we could do an episode
on the logistical challenges of making
something like enter the matrix like it
is i have 12 minutes and you're right it
takes vision it takes like a it takes
like a creative
goal and dream but yeah i mean
we can go into it
why were you just prefacing sony alana i
said i'm very interested to see what
sony does with um their approach to
films like i i don't not have any
insider information but obviously we
know about ghost sushima
last of us tv show um i'm where is there
a ghost tv show movie
movie i believe it's a charge right yeah
i'm like very curious to see what their
approach is to that because i mean it's
already obviously kurosawa-esque very
cinematic game um
it's very cinematic like i'm i'm
interested to see like do they just
do the same thing with those issues
i don't think they're using daisuke but
i don't know if they've announced look
i'm far be it from me to you know
chastise that decision
i think they should use it
that's who it is
no i just i just it is a wonderful
tangent i'm like do i want to take that
exit ramp
um yeah i don't think
um so actually it's
chad's john wick
director john wick yeah who's doing the
ghost tsushima movie i don't know who
has told me how easy he would find it to
kill me in the past so you know we have
no cast members currently attached um
and i don't think we even know
it's okay so it says it intends to be a
faithful adaptation according to
inverse.com but
i'm very because i feel like yeah we're
gonna [ __ ] this up
yeah that's the press release they're in
a good position to be able to pull this
off with some of these properties and
and
they also are probably the studio with
the strongest overlap of high grossing
knock out the park like genuinely like
hit the way he the way he puts his
action scenes together the way i mean if
they're the biggest lesson working with
with
him and the the stunt guys was like and
this is just pure name dropping but it's
true like they're the way they
choreograph john wick it is a melee
combat movie it just happens that it's
they're using guns like the way they
design all of that action is so
built around those the close body
interactions like yeah
that that guy's gonna kill it with
swords you know what's interesting the
best sword fights in sarah flynn saying
you i'm sure already know this
mike uh but this was news to me i i was
looking up
chad on imdb right now
yeah
foreign he was in the matrix
he
there's some great pictures of him on
the set of the matrix he what's
interesting is that he
usually if you direct a hit movie
that is your career trajectory as from
that point forward you are now a
director because you will have
opportunities to direct come your way
people will be sending you scripts
but curiously
inter after the first john wick and
interwoven with the subsequent sequels
he was the
uh
action unit director of hitman agent 47
in 2015 he was the second unit director
of captain america civil war he was the
st
doesn't surprise me it does not surprise
me at all well isn't that how a lot of
the marvel movies are done that there's
kind of the director who does the
dialogue but second unit director is
usually always much lower on the totem
pole it depends though if second second
i think in marvel isn't that like a code
word in marvel movies second unit second
unit means that's predominantly stunts
so
that's the pitch
yeah second unit is is typically now
going to be
we are if you have a splinter unit your
splinter unit could be doing b-roll
establishing shots all that stuff but
second unit is almost you look and
second unit's always gonna list second
unit director stunt coordinator a lot of
times the stunt coordinator will be the
second unit director so it's always
gonna be stunned so it makes perfect
sense the most badass
stunt movie guys like i need you to
bring in that sensibility because i got
this fight in an elevator i'm like oh
[ __ ] dude i'll show you how to do that
yeah he was amazing he was sexy
where it's just the camera spanning
along and he loves he likes his video
game so like you can see that video game
brawler kind of he was the second unit
also on birds of prey the the um
interesting i love the choreography in
birds of prey
it happens a lot like with these with
these superheroes
you bring in the director to do the
director of note on these movies is
often the one who's focused on like the
storytelling the characters but like
there's a reason the action in these
films is
a such a high level and be kind of
consistent between movies and it's
because a lot of that stuff is either
worked out by a great second unit or by
um previews my takeaways
go ahead sorry no that's okay
go ahead please you have been cut off
repeatedly
well i i
i just want to jump in
again i was going to say the um the
thing that makes that still surprising
though is because
you know
if you're a you know
now a big name director the bandwidth
required to take on a
new film like in like in chad's case you
know uh john wick four usually the
development and all that associated with
that you can't just bounce out to go
do second unit on another movie quite as
easily and plus it's you're you're sort
of you've built your name to such a
place and now you're second field to
someone else like birds of prey was no
film but you know how unsurprised you
are because of troy's personality that
when you hear that he's like in 50
things this week what desperate chad has
the same energy yeah desperation well
he's between jobs
i think he's probably directing five
movies at the same time right now i also
you could go in and you could second
unit direct like
he could that is a much smaller time
commitment yeah they're like hey right
now we are um this is prepping so
they're probably working on sets and
everything else they're scouting could
be so he's like i really don't need to
be there for scouting you guys know what
i need if he has a great location scout
that he trusts or a first aid deed that
he really really trusts so he could be
doing that i'm speculating of course
whilst he get calls in he's like hey we
have two weeks of second unit on captain
america we're gonna pay you a shitload
of money to come and do he's like great
like i'm gonna do that knock that out in
two weeks
i mean it's it probably keeps him fresh
and sharp and says opposed to just like
all i can think about for the last six
years is john wick are you kidding me
well you know also how the action team
the action team will prepare a lot of
this stuff like in the gym
before you're even anywhere near a set
like once they know the the volume of
the fight sequence you know you've got
in hollywood now several of these teams
and they just drill and build up a scene
and often that well usually that will
include kind of ideas about camera and
all that stuff so you end up with these
and these are on the internet right
these awesome kind of pre-visualizations
of key fight scenes and movies where
it's them running around with toy guns
in a gym
but you know a lot of the work is worked
out there and a good action director
trusts his but it's also
the conversation we're having right now
applies to so many people in an industry
of all the set visits that i've done i
remember like venom really stood out to
me because they like it was raining we
had to wait for the rain to stop for
them to get their their shots and
you know almost everyone there is just
candidly talking about oh do you
remember the time we were filming the
dark knight and this happened and this
happened like all of these people have
worked on so many things for so long and
and the takeaway i always get from these
conversations is the amount of people
that we don't give any credit to
it's like the
huge amount of people that we're just
like oh he did that and then you're like
but think about all of the people who
are stunt coordinators and all the stunt
actors and then we don't even know the
writers of half of these movies we just
know the one director's name and the
leads name and it's like so many people
work on these things oh my gosh
like where do you bring up like like
writer because like derek colstad who
wrote um the john wicks
like the career he's had since like in
the number of movies his name pops up on
never heard of him just did never heard
he just but he the the dude is working
totally but we never know the names of
like people
was his or at least he was one of the
this is one reason why i kind of like
i wish the oscars would go back to being
a closed door event
you know
because the whole red carpet thing takes
away from the little guy because they're
not advertising friendly yeah remember
when they remember when they had the
short film
categories like best documentary short
whatever in the the for one year they
tried as an experiment having the the
nominees received their oscar in the
aisle they weren't allowed up on stage
uh i mean can you know what kind of does
that like i i award shows complex oh
yeah during breaks it's like by the way
during the break we gave away four
awards anyway
yeah and i understand it's it's from a
desire for keely to recognize as many
people as he can he's got a
you can only buy so much air time people
give keely [ __ ] for the guy i love the
dude he's genuinely trying to do
something he loves video games he's not
trying to take his video games yeah um
and he has
when i found out that he had personally
invested his money to make that show
happen i was like yo man
i i gotta give it to you and the fact
that he is is is working on iterating it
every year making it better and better
and better um for the single cause of of
really elevating it and saying and not
just being as good as the oscars but
just trying to give people in the
writers and the riggers and the lighters
and everybody else their due he's like
but nobody wants and i can only do that
if people
pay for it and if i can only get people
to pay if there's things that are
happening that people don't like yeah so
it's just dealing with the devil that i
totally understand
but i just i wish that
i wish that i knew more about
the the different people i always stay
all the way through the credits it's a
stupid thing it doesn't matter no one
gets any more recognition or more money
if i sit in my seat until if i'm in the
movie theater and watch all the credits
but how great that marvel has gamified
that and everyone stays through the
credits i saw no one gets up anymore i
love movies as well i love it it's
always brilliant i love i i've i've
noticed that the last handful of times
that it's so institutionalized like it i
was i saw shang chi which was excellent
actually i loved it way more than i
expected to and yeah the fact that
95 of the audience stays planted and
it's not like they erupt into loud
conversation either and it becomes like
this lounge because nobody knows when
they're going to do it but the thing
that sucks is then they did the real
credits like the rest of the credits
that happen afterwards and then
everybody gets up and leaves no but they
always do too
yeah they have another scene at the very
end of the end i mean that's that's
that's like with you know as as someone
with you know with kerry obviously is
often in the kind of the role of those
credits like later down the road right
and it's it's it's it's awesome just and
with with what's really funny is those
in massively long disney plus
credits now that we they're on there um
because because we just got a few
friends who've worked on a couple of
those and like the number of people who
scroll past and and yeah it's it's it's
games it's called marvel where it's a
lot of video games although then you
watch something like i loved it with um
horizon zero dawn i remember being just
amazed by how few people worked on that
like with video games i'm often
surprised the other way where it's like
you did this with this size team and
they're still massive teams that was
going to say that's not a small
matter it's not a small team
but also like you were always crediting
this like genuinely similar ghost of
sushima like quite a quite a specific
team yeah one of the smaller studios
weirdly
um i have to run but same
related to uh giving people thanks it is
episode 75
it made it to 75 episodes so i wanted to
say
exactly
thank you to everybody for watching the
show thank you to our editor jack who
edits the show thanks jack thank you to
[Music]
karen who is an artist who made this fan
art that you can see behind me if you're
watching which one of my friends
i get the one with the blonde hair there
you go see oh my god
can we get some stint i look like i look
like uh i look like seth rogen a little
bit
well this is all uh
new match that we're dropping for
episode 75 that will be available on
redbubble.com people play what's listen
i believe i will make sure to put that
in the link in the description on
youtube and also give a shout out to
karen i'm a really big fan of her uh she
this is something that she just made and
then i was like can i buy that and sell
it and so i think i'll snip my my
mine out of there and make that like my
new
like it's super cute and also is already
in the circle shape so i think it would
fit super nicely i love it i uh i look
different
you do that's the problem you're the
most variable
this is this was between this before i
fell on hard times
uh by the way the 16 year old's back
but he's different now
this is what i do now very incredible
join the bike again but i'm 16 years old
very good thanks for watching episode 70
[ __ ] whatever play wards listen
my name is the 16 year old i think that
over there
this
no you have to do it all now you have to
intro the show it's on you now all right
do the full intro all right
this is why unions have rules about how
long you do this right here that's a lot
of fish is a video game right
this right here is the mike bethel he's
a video game maker that's us awesome
wintry
this guy knows what more bodies are
buried down in lombok you shouldn't know
about he's also a video game composer
i'm a 16 year old that likes to play
video games
bye bye everybody
incredible and the award
goes to
greg miller
greg camilla well done craig great we're
very proud of you all right bye guys